hello everyone and yippie kaye to all
you roy rogers fans out there welcome to
versus i'm your host mark ellis and
today we have one of the most
anticipated matchups in the history of
our show something bad is about to
happen
i can feel it it's an all-out
ass-kicking a-lister action ambush or a
roll-up king red box rigamarole rife
with rottenness because we have nicolas
cage taking on bruce willis they've made
some of the greatest films for the past
40 years some of the worst movies in the
history of hollywood and they've made
like 70 movies that no one's ever heard
of airstrike a score to settle out of
death are those even real movies i have
no idea this is going to be fun in one
quarter you have nick cage when he's not
making award-winning rom-coms or an
introspective tragedy he's probably off
looking for the holy grail or a t-rex
arm in the other corner is bruce willis
when he's not making a blockbuster
action movie he's probably making a
sequel to one of those action movies
look say what you want about these two
actors seriously go ahead and belt it
out because it's probably accurate but
you can't say that they're not two of
the most prolific and talented
performers we've ever seen on the big
screen when their films make it to the
big screen here's how we'll determine a
winner round one box office round two
tomato meters slash audio score round
three home on the range round four
memorable moments and then we'll do a
wild card round that i so want to call
red box receipts but i don't know if we
have that data or how to collect it it
might be a simple google search or maybe
red boxes like netflix and they lock up
their stats in a box stored right next
to the ark of the covenant which is
probably something that nick cage has
spent extensive time and resources
looking for well one thing is for sure
how have we never gotten a movie
starring both nick cage and bruce willis
maybe we run back conair for another
fight or they team up his buddies for
the next to last boy scout figure it out
tinseltown all right
let's get it on round one box office so
i opened the floodgates for you to say
what you want about nic cage and bruce
willis but their box office appeal over
the years has been undeniably epic even
though they seem content to crank out
tons of forgettable streaming flicks
these days with an occasional big screen
gem that reminds us why we used to love
them once upon a time in hollywood they
were as bankable and as big time as it
got and the amount of butts they put in
seats in their heyday might be unrivaled
after having modest hits in the 1980s
with films like fast times at ridgemont
high raising arizona and peggy sue got
married nick cage's starring role in
1987's moonstruck saw his star on the
rise along with the box office towie
that film grossed 80 million dollars
worldwide and elevated him into a
certifiable leading man then the summer
of 96 happened his unlikely reluctant
action star mold struck gold with the
rock and that popcorn blow him up good
speeded its way to 336 million dollars
on the big screen
the next year cage had two monster hits
in one summer as conair's 224 million
dollars was the opening act for
face-offs 241 million the very next
month but if we're talking action stars
bruce willis deserves a seat at the head
table the perfect blend of
schwarzenegger stallone muscly
one-liners and a hesitant hero like cage
willis landed the role of john mclean in
1988's die-hard and instantly concocted
a new breed of adventure protagonist
part swashbuckler part regular joe with
a dash of luck tossed in willis's
charisma propelled that first diehard
entry to a 130 million dollar gross
making it the super rare film that
doubles as one of the highest grossing
march releases ever along with being one
of the most profitable christmas movies
in history in case you were still
wondering yes it is
moving on to more explosions and witty
bruno reactions die hard 2 and the 5th
element each grossed well over 200
million dollars die hard with a
vengeance took in
366 million and 1998's armageddon made
554 million bucks even better is it
harry stamper never had to pay taxes on
any of that what's that oh right he
doesn't uh ooh well we'll get to that
later so we know cage and willis can
make an action or worth seeing but their
legacy spans all the sections of
blockbuster video especially new
releases if those stores are still
around they might have to build like
some more shelves to accommodate all the
product that nick and bruce are
currently turning and burning but let's
stick to the silver screen and the other
movies that made a small fortune like
cage's family fare combo of the croods
and spider-man into the spider-verse
which team up for an almost billion
dollar haul or the sappy romance city of
angels a film that googooed its way to a
198 million dollar take imagine being an
angel having all that power and then you
go and fall in love with a human oh
tragic meanwhile willis has throwers
like the sixth sense which conjured 672
million dollars in 1999 sci-fi epics
like looper and 12 monkeys each of which
notched around 170 million dollars and
the genre defying pulp fiction which
punched in 212 million dollars thanks to
the eye of a former hollywood video
clerk turned director cage also pads his
resume with the national treasure hits
those two flicks have done almost 800
million dollars combined the 231 million
dollar grossing gone in 60 seconds and
the og ghost rider which revved up 229
million worldwide don't worry john
blaise enthusiast the sequel was also a
hit taking in 149 million dollars hey
did y'all know the sorcerer's apprentice
did over 200 million dollars
that's got to be the least talked about
200 million movie ever right like i saw
it i liked it fine and then i forgot it
happened like five minutes later weird
bruce willis kept making die hard
sequels and we kept showing up for some
reason entries four and five each did
well over 300 million dollars the family
rom-com look who's talking spit up 297
million dollars and both unbreakable and
glass shattered expectations with each
one breaking the 240 million dollar
barrier if you think i'm having way too
much fun finding euphemisms for earned x
amount of dollars you're right and i
will not apologize all told we got us a
close race here nick cage movies average
101 million dollars per big screen
outing bruce willis films average 124
million per appearance wow these guys
really are stars when they're not
weighed down by those other movies they
make now available on vod but willis
flexes his biceps for the death blow
that's gotta be a movie one of them made
right death blow when we look at the
total box office moolah bruce has taken
in 8.33 billion dollars in his career
nicholas 6.19 billion stellar stats all
around but bruce willis wins round one
and takes a one nothing lead
round two tomato meter slash audience
score after doing some careful research
there is a 1987 movie called death blow
starring you guessed it frank stallone
there's no tomato meter score for that
classic yet but the veggie patch in the
audience have had plenty to say about
the works of nick cage and bruce willis
throughout the years and unlike that
movie theater round here the streamers
the red boxes the video on demands they
all count i'm on the edge of my seat
we'll start with the good news and
there's plenty to be had it gives this
host great pleasure to announce that
between the two of them nick and bruce
have 12 movies currently residing at 90
or above on the tomato meter cage acts
as a kenobi because here he has the high
ground thanks to a trio of films at 97
percent pig red rock west and into the
spider verse moonstruck is at 94 percent
tying it with willis's best effort some
little action movie called die hard
looper and moonrise kingdom are at 93
percent face-off and pulp fiction are
both at 92 percent and nobody's full and
leaving las vegas are at 91 percent as
is raising arizona good job boys we like
you we really like you other fresh
notables for bruce include 12 monkeys at
89 percent the six cents at 86 percent
and sin city at 77
cage counters with an 86 percent for joe
valley girl at 83 percent and kick ass
at 76 percent man he was great as big
daddy in that but the granddaddy of all
modern action movies is die hard and
bruce willis calling card franchise
sports two more films in fresh town you
want to take a guess okay die hard 2 69
and
live free or die hard at 82 percent yes
it's true die hard with a vengeance is
59
rotten putting it on hallowed ground
with space balls for oh so close to
freshness don't worry there's a podcast
called rotten tomatoes is wrong i know
the hosts and i will be making some
calls okay so remember how i said we had
a bunch of movies that were above 90
ah those were the days but now every
action has a reaction what goes up must
come down and these two great actors
share the scar of having a brace
yourself 26 combined movies coming in
under 10
on the tomato meter let's see if we've
heard of any of them midnight in the
switchgrass is it eight percent cosmic
sin is at three percent and hard kill is
a flat line at zero percent those are
bruce willis movies and he's got eight
other winners at zero percent the whole
10 yards is at least a movie i've heard
of and that's at four percent which is
not good i did enjoy the original nine
yards and that's at 43 percent which
isn't all that good unless you say that
immediately after nine flicks hit zero
percent cage has deadfall in grand
island zero percent and left behind got
one percent which somehow sounds worse
than zero at least commit to your
stinkiness season of the witch is at 11
and the infamous wicker man bees its way
to 15 also of note is the cage stars in
the 2019 film called running with the
devil the van halen song is as fresh as
they come but the critics weren't
talking about love here as it's only at
24
you're not exactly lighting up the sky
with that one but overall nick cage does
have a decent average on the tomato
meter earning 47 per flick thank you pig
willis averages 38 so he'll be looking
at the audience score to help him stay
in the contest and it does he's much
closer to fresh on that metric averaging
52 percent per flick that number is
buoyed by pulp fiction's 96 percent die
hard's 94 percent and die hard with a
vengeance is 83
finally justice armageddon is 73 and the
last boy scout is also fresh at 68
percent it's a solid football movie cage
crowd pleasers like the croods a new age
help out his audience score outlook the
sequel's at 94 percent while the og is
at 77 percent the rock sneaks up to 85
percent tying itself with raising
arizona adaptation and leaving las vegas
we kind of get away from the crowd
police return with the vegas movie but
it's still really really good all told
cage only trails bruce by an average of
one percent here as his audience score
perfect number is 51
and now fun fact somehow nick cage
direct-to-streaming movies have a 33
tomato meter average on their own if
that doesn't sound impressive it should
that's like a monumental feat especially
when you consider that alongside
willis's vod movies because they average
eight percent come on critics no love
for 10 minutes gone or acts of violence
or even apex the movie's called apex but
it's at zero percent nick cage is too
strong at the top and has less absolute
stinkers than bruce willis so he'll take
the win in this round and we got
ourselves a tied ball game one to one
round three home on the range when you
hear that a round is titled after a
classic western tune you might think
it'll be won by who plays the better
lonesome cowboy type and you'd be kinda
right bruce willis played a cool drifter
back in the day for last man standing
and nick cage literally raised arizona
but the type of range we're talking
about here is acting range how diverse
is your resume and how many different
types of roles have you taken on over
the years so yeah starring in a western
might help but you know what else would
being the world's biggest action star
then appearing completely against type
in death becomes her that's what bruce
willis did to much acclaim opposite
meryl streep and goldie hawn the dark
comedy was a hit and his beleaguered
schweb was a scene stealer bruce willis
obviously has that wisecracking tough
guy thing down to his size he could do
that role in his sleep but he can also
strike your funny bone such as when he
lent his voice to a baby and look who's
talking the sequels kind of went off the
rails but that first one still holds up
with a ton of laughs will is his
penchant for rom-cominess which is a
word i promise to never use again goes
all the way back to his breakout tv role
on moonlighting and his first box office
success blind date early career cage was
tough to type cast other than playing a
guy with bedhead it worked in fast times
raising arizona valley girl peggy sue
got married but then just when he
thought he found his calling card as a
rom-com lead with a slate david lynchian
darkness he assumed the mantle once held
by bruce willis and became america's
favorite action star roles like the
super reluctant stanley goodspeed and
the rock gave way to the kind of
reluctant cameron poe in conair and
eventually became the very non-reluctant
caster troy in face-off kids that's a
one-year span where he played the
ultimate good guy the classic good guy
with a past and then an absolute
psychopath who then swaps faces with
another ultimate good guy thus getting
to play both parts will has continued
his penchant for comedy by making an
extended run in the sitcom friends and
starring in the 2000 family romp the kid
and although he's never been nominated
for an oscar he got lots of buzz for
roles in sci-fi epics like 12 monkeys
and looper cage has been nominated twice
winning once for leaving las vegas but
whereas nick cage can feel like an
over-the-top presence in real life he's
able to more easily disappear into a
variety of roles than willis bruce can
be great but even in comedies like the
whole nine yards he's still playing a
tough guy just for laughs instead of
chills their forays into horror have
been solid leading with films like the
sixth sense and the glass trilogy for
willis for cage there's the hilarious
wicker man moments but also the
psychedelic madness of mandy the
unhinged intensity of frank in bringing
out the dead and in one of his own
favorite roles peter lowe in vampire's
kiss it's a tough call here because i do
feel like when bruce willis commits he
can play just about anything as his wes
anderson film resume would indicate but
that bass line is almost always going to
be a cool everyman like john mcclane
nick cage on the other hand i don't know
if he has a bass line i guess it would
be
unpredictable and it's that quality that
can lead to a breath of rolls that are
too much to ignore the coppola kid gets
a win in round three and he's rested a
two to one lead from jimmy the tulip
tudoski
what does that mean over
round four memorable moments
as many laughs as we've had today
courtesy of bruce
film festival of zero percenters and as
many chortles as we've had over the
years thanks to nick cage's singular uh
cageyness i would still contend that the
most memorable moments that these two
have had over the years have been in
fact intentional our shared movie going
experiences simply wouldn't be as
remarkable had we not had the explosions
the emotions
and okay the bees the bees
i love my eyes
nick cage came out of the gate with a
few great moments there was no shortage
in films like moonstruck but nothing
typifies early nick cage energy better
than raising arizona and it's because in
every sequence he's one maniacal laugh
away from becoming woody woodpecker that
frenetic creature was something of an
inspiration for cage's h.i mcdonough and
the coen brothers allowed him to run
with it for all-out cage zaniness that
actually works in the context of the
film relax worker man we're not talking
about you yet i'd go with his very
warranted freakouts in mandy or his
emotional outburst since scorsese's
bringing out the dead bruce willis has
also created moments that reflect his
best on-screen persona a tough guy with
a heart and a sense of humor i'm going
right for the jugular with armageddon
it's a star-studded lineup for sure but
it's bruce's movie from start to
sacrificial finish for some reason this
movie still gets me choked up when harry
pulls the old switcharoo on ben affleck
to ensure that betty is gonna make it
home safely then the very next year the
brooding investigation into why a little
boy sees dead people featured a stunning
reveal that still hits home decades
later not only did haley joel osment see
dead people he also could have seen a
future where bruce and ennight shyamalan
would team up for more notable sequences
david dunn discovering his powers while
doing the typical dad in the garage
bench press workout in unbreakable is
awesome and seeing dunn again forwarding
crime at the outset of glass was a
welcome return for over-the-top
nuttiness the choice would be nick cage
he can go completely bat as villain
castor troy
[Applause]
or as a bee hater the likes we haven't
seen since macaulay culkin and my girl
but i would prefer it channeled through
the david lynch prism in a film like
wild at heart how better to unleash the
fury that is nicolas cage than with
laura dern a convertible and the open
road plus karate moshing cage is equally
adept at lending personality to a big
family adventure like the national
treasure movies as benjamin gates his
obsessive nature is channeled into
priceless artifacts very similar to some
guy named indiana but whereas jones is
always cool and suave gates can unravel
pretty quick but he's even faster to
recover just in time to save the day of
course any memorable moment involving
saving the day will be taking a silver
medal to bruce willis in die hard that's
his trump card in this round and he's
got five movies worth of greatness okay
maybe four move maybe three and a
quarter die hard with a vengeance gave
us a stunning opening sequence set to
the love and spoonful then we get a
heaping helping of sam jackson and bruce
for the duration i still love watching
the reveal of who the baddie torturing
mclean this time really is and the
elevator scene where jon has to take
matters into his own hands is an
all-timer die hard 2 has an epic finish
involving a fuel weak a plane and a
lighter and then cable tv gave us the
blessing of the worst voice dub in
history to this day i have no idea what
yipikaye mr falcon means but i'm here
for it but of course the mic drop moment
is the end of the first die hard a film
that plays as one long memorable moment
where we blow up the roof of nakatomi
plaza john mclean has to think quick and
rig a fire hose as an escape valve and
just in the nick of time he makes a
daring leap as a raging inferno blazes
behind him it's the definitive shot of
any action film ever in my opinion and
with as many die-hard knock-offs as
we've had since no movie has been able
to top the original one guy pushed past
his limits riff since maybe nick cage
could have gotten there if we kept
getting more national treasures why did
we stop making those they were huge
right oh yeah nick might have taken a
break from movies to actually go look
for treasure like the holy grail
seriously he ended up in vermont i think
which is not exactly how it went in the
last crusade but who knows i mean tom
brady was in new england maybe the holy
grail was there too bruce willis wins
this round thanks to a deciding blow
from john mclean and now we're tied at
two to two heading into the final round
is it just a matter of time
before a man opens his eyes
and gives up his one
dream
is one dream of happiness and now it's
time for the wild card round wow what a
difference blockbuster video that was
the theme song for america's most
popular rental chain my town
williamsburg virginia was too small for
one of them so we had video update we
had all the same sections blockbuster
had and we also had the curtain remember
the curtain i'll tell you kids about it
when you're old enough regardless of
where you or your parents might have
rented physical media way back in the
day that's where this deciding round
will be taking place a virtual video
store where i'll take the best cajun
willis flicks from each section and see
whose collection comes out on top i'm
gonna take one film from each for the
big four comedy action drama and horror
slash thriller and then for funsies i'm
actually gonna go outside and grab one
movie from the zero percent dregs of red
box yeah i'm actually going to watch
them and i'm kind of really excited
about it action movies is where we start
and cage has a mountain to climb we know
what movie is going to represent team
willis here does nick have any chance
well if you had to scale a mountain it
would be nice to have the rock on your
side for my money i consider this to be
the best or second best action film of
the 1990s depending on how recent it's
been since i last saw point break cage
and sean connery are so good as a
mismatched pair breaking into yes into
alcatraz to rescue hostages from a
crazed ed harris as much as i adore die
hard 2 and 3 i think the rock might get
the nod from me but nothing tops the
inaugural die hard the coolest premise
is sometimes the simplest and that film
taught us all how therapeutic making
fist with your toes can be and it wins
the action section what do you think i'm
effing stupid hans on to comedy we ride
where the competition might get a little
tighter willis has a few solid ones
although none could ever quite match the
wit timing and chemistry he achieved on
tv opposite civil shepherd in
moonlighting i'm gonna give him the
whole nine yards because we get laughs
from all over matthew perry's physical
antics amanda pete's conniving innocence
michael clark duncan's imposing visage
and bruce's jimmy the tulip tying it all
together the laugh out loud moment for
me is when jimmy tosses a shocked
matthew perry a beer immediately after
the tulip shot someone on a boat perry
is still aghast as the beer goes soaring
by into the water it is knee slapping
stuff cage has a good ace in this round
with a few different cards i could go
moonstruck or matchstick men but i'm
sticking with raising arizona fast times
only featured him in passing but arizona
had him front and center as a guy
completely overwhelmed with the recent
events in his life the coming out party
for cage and the cohens gets my vote
here and we're tied at one to one as we
head over to drama cage won an oscar for
leaving las vegas and deservedly so but
here i'm leaning towards the film that
earned him a second nomination
adaptation he plays charlie kaufman and
occasionally portrays his brother too in
a role that is so twisted dark and
hopeful all at the same time it's a
whimsical romp that keeps both feet
firmly in the drama section and speaking
of romps i guess the best category for
pulp fiction is drama there's just so
much here and although willis isn't the
proper lead he packs a punch as a down
and out boxer much like raising arizona
was just as big for the coen brothers as
it was for cage so too was pulp fiction
a giant shot in the arm for director
quentin tarantino it changed the game in
hollywood and an a-list star like bruce
willis helped shift that tide pulp
fiction gets a close win
wait a minute i forgot about pig pig is
the drama i'm going with for cage in
this sudden wrestlemania event and
because cage is the star of that and
willis is a side player in pulp fiction
i'm reversing my decision and giving the
nod to cage
big beats fiction ping beats fiction i
know i know unbelievable all right let's
settle down before we hit horror
thriller as much as you all want me to
pick the wicker man for cage i refuse to
do so especially when mandy is just
waiting right there it is not for the
faint of heart and make sure your
friends and family know what they're
getting into before hitting play but if
you're on board it is bonkers in the
best nick cage way possible but bruce
willis has a secret that not even he
knows in the sixth sense besides being
maybe the biggest spoiler in tinsel town
since darth vader took a dna test on the
maury povich show the sixth sense
succeeds as a spine-tingling back of
your neck tickling thriller from start
to finish the build is slow and
relentless and it's still satisfying to
revisit knowing what we know now hey
wasn't nick cajun knowing yeah that was
a cool movie but the sixth sense just
hits different the horror thriller
section has been claimed by willis and
now it all comes down to what's behind
the curtain no not that curtain you
teenage perverts the red box won i took
a zero percenter from each actor's
library
and wow what an experience that was for
willis i went with out of death because
that was the funniest title what does
that even mean like death is out of
stock like toilet paper was a couple
years ago bruce plays a retired forest
ranger helping a woman who saw a grizzly
crime and the dude looks like he wants
to stay retired hollywood loris aids sid
willis makes a handsome sum for these
movies the check clears he shows up for
a week of work and that's all you get
one week and then just make the rest of
the movie around those scenes for nick
cage i don't know what his contract is
maybe he shows up for a week or maybe
he's on set every day for free handing
out homemade pastries to the crew you
really can't tell with that guy but he
committed to grand isle this 2019 thrill
ride stars nick is a vietnam vet with
many demons and a very troubled past and
he forgot his and his wife's 15th
anniversary talk about embarrassing
right it's nowhere near as easy to fall
asleep to as the straightforward out of
death was you really could swap these
movie titles it would make more sense
but cage has a couple monologues towards
the end of grand isle about honor that
remind you how talented the guy really
is neither film is going to be viewed by
me or possibly anyone ever again on
purpose but grand isle is better thus
nick cage wins the blockbuster fight
takes the wild card round and thus the
whole match
[Applause]
oh what a freakist that was and as much
glee as i might get busting these guys
as chops good-naturedly i do in my heart
believe that bruce willis and nick cage
still have that greatness in them and i
so root for a career resurgence he's got
a new movie coming out where he plays a
heightened version of himself which for
nick cage is just himself nick cage
takes it over bruce wells today but
that's just my opinion now i turn it
over to you dear viewer hit me up on
social media with your take at mark
ellis live and let me know what other
vod flicks from willis or cage you've
seen whether by accident or on purpose
and i'm being serious i love these guys
as actors i saw die hard with a
vengeance twice opening day and so if
you give me the go-ahead i'm gonna watch
it until then this is versus i'm mark
ellis but you can call me roy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you